this episode was proudly made possible
by Subaru there's a great line by
Shakespeare in which he says we know
what we are we know not what we may be
and in the age of accelerating
technologies in which we extend the
cognitive reach of our mind the
perimeters of our humanists with these
extensions of self these exoskeletons
these technological scaffoldings you
know the wings of our aircrafts and the
signals traveling through our smartphone
sending our thoughts electrified at the
speed of light across oceans of sky we
redefine and extend what it means to be
human
Edward o Wilson says we have actually
decommissioned natural selection and now
we must look deep within ourselves and
decide what we wish to be common we are
now the key agents of evolution
we have reversed engineered the software
of biology er and about to rewire and
upgrade it we define what it is to be a
homo sapien Juan Enriquez uses the term
homo evolutis the being that evolves
itself and trend
itself right reycarts while we didn't
stay in the caves haven't made on the
planet biology just
membrane can be transcended you know
Marvin Minsky used to say will robots
inherit the earth yes they will but they
will be our children you know I love
this idea because we hear the term
transhumanism and what it means to be
human is to be trans human we are the
species that transforms and transcend we
never stop we always did it's what we
are
be sure to check out second chance
Subaru at revision3.com / Subaru